So when a couple of months ago, we got these
really wild polls, nationally, polls that
had Donald Trump down to Joe Biden by 10 points
nationally, by 12 points nationally, there
were even a few that said Donald Trump was
down by 15 points nationally.
I said at the time whether or not those polls
were accurate at the time and remember, accurate
means within the margin of error.
So if it says fifteen, it could really be
eight depending on the margin of error.
I repeated at the time, it is very unlikely
that on Election Day we're going to see a
10 point margin in the popular vote.
It's just extraordinarily unlikely.
I don't think any of us should be imagining
that that's the case.
We should imagine it's going to be much tighter
and it means we all have to vote at the same
time.
If these polls keep coming out, we can't really
ignore them.
And indeed, there are now multiple new polls
that have Joe Biden up by 12.
There is a new Reuters Ipsos poll which says
that Joe Biden leads Donald Trump by 12 points
nationally.
That's among likely voters, 52 to 40.
There's also a new USC poll which says Joe
Biden is up by 12.
And importantly, in that one, Joe Biden is
polling at 53 percent.
So in both the Reuters Ipsos poll and the
USC poll, not only is Donald Trump losing
by double digits, but Joe Biden is over 50
percent support, which is an important metric
to keep an eye on.
Now, in these polls, somewhere between three
and five percent of likely voters say they're
just undecided right now.
Now, I've talked about this before.
Who are those people?
How could you possibly be undecided at this
point unless you literally not paid attention
to politics?
And in that case, how likely are you to actually
vote?
That's a question.
If we say the electorate is expected to be
about one hundred and thirty million people,
if five percent are undecided.
That is six and a half million voters right
now.
Six and a half million voters who are looking
at this situation and saying, I might vote
Biden or I might vote Trump.
I continue to be stunned and appalled by that
reality.
I would love to talk to some of those undecided
voters.
I invite you to call in.
I've not heard from any of them so far.
Now, it's really important to remember that
a popular vote margin correlates differently
to the likelihood of an electoral victory
for Democrats versus Republicans.
There is a structural imbalance against Democrats
where, as you know, sometimes Democrats win
the popular vote and don't become president
because they lose the Electoral College, as
I'm sure you remember, unless you're four
years old, in which case I don't even know
that we have four year olds in our audience
in 2016.
Donald Trump lost the popular vote by two
point one, but he won the Electoral College
thanks to 70 something thousand votes in three
states.
Nate Silver from 538 did something important.
He crunched the numbers to tell us, given
a particular popular vote margin.
How likely is it that Joe Biden will win the
Electoral College?
And again, understand that the numbers are
skewed in this way because of the urban rural
divide and because of some other sort of base
level factors that favor Republicans in the
Electoral College, even at the even while
being at a disadvantage in the popular vote.
So if Joe Biden wins the popular vote by under
one point, his odds of becoming president
of getting 270 electoral votes are only six
percent.
If Joe Biden can win the popular vote by one
to two points, he has a 22 percent chance
of winning the Electoral College.
If Joe Biden matches Hillary Clinton's popular
vote win somewhere in the two to three point
range, it is still slightly more likely that
Trump wins the Electoral College.
In other words, if Biden gets a similar margin
of victory in the popular vote to Hillary,
he only has a 46 percent chance of winning
the Electoral College.
That's why we all have to vote only when Joe
Biden's popular vote lead gets beyond three
points.
Does Joe Biden become the likely candidate
to become president if he wins between three
and four points in the popular vote.
He has a 74 percent chance of being president.
And as you can see, if Joe Biden were to get
a six point popular vote win.
The odds of becoming president go above ninety
nine percent.
If in some other universe Joe Biden actually
were to win the popular vote by 10.
It would be all but certain that he becomes
the next president of the United States.
So that's how I would be thinking about the
popular vote versus the electoral vote scenario.
Now, let's look at Joe Biden's average lead
right now, because the 12 point lead is not
representative of the average.
If you look at Joe Biden's average in all
national polls, he's up by six point nine.
Okay.
If Joe Biden were to win by six point nine,
as I just showed you.
He will almost certainly win the Electoral
College, right?
Well, yes and no if he really wins by six
point nine, yes.
But remember that there is a margin of error
here.
Now, when you're averaging poll results, you
can't just say, OK.
Biden's up by six point nine.
If the average poll has a three percent margin
of error for each candidate, that means maybe
Joe's only up by zero point nine.
There are some complex mathematics involved
in figuring out an overall margin of error
when you're already averaging poll results,
which in and of themselves have margins of
error.
It doesn't matter.
The point is Hillary Clinton ended up with
a popular vote win.
That was two thirds the size of what the polling
predicted.
So let me put it a different way.
Hillary Clinton was expected to win by three
in the polls.
She won by two.
That means her real margin was two thirds
of the expected margin.
If we apply that to Joe Biden, if we say,
OK, Biden is winning by six point nine, but
we're only expecting him to win by two thirds
of that.
That would be about a four point popular vote
margin of victory.
If that were the case, it still doesn't guarantee
victory for Joe Biden, but it certainly starts
to look pretty good.
What does this mean?
This means we all have to vote.
That's really all that this means.
And even though the popular vote numbers may
be looking pretty good, we do have to talk
about something that's going on in Minnesota,
which is not looking quite so good.